if you think watching the mandalorian is
the way here are five other titles
totally worth checking out on this
week's binge guide
the first ever live action series in the
star wars universe is a
huge hit with critics and it has become
employment tv viewing for fans so if you
can't get enough of this lone bounty
hunter traveling the outer reaches of
the galaxy with the cutest unlikely
passenger
in episodes that feel like mini western
movies then this list
is for you starting with our throwback
pick the man with no name movie trilogy
with an average tomato meter score of 95
and high audience scores across the
board
this trilogy of spaghetti western movies
from sergio leone a fistful of dollars
for a few dollars more and the good the
bad and the ugly all feature clint
eastwood as the anti-hero the man with
no name
critics have said that the final
installment is arguably the greatest of
the spaghetti westerns and that these
films help to find a new era for the
genre while ushering in its most iconic
star in clint eastwood
so if you're quick on the draw you can
binge this whole trilogy in about six
and a half hours so
go ahead it'll make your day and
lighting things up with our audience
pick this week
is the fox series firefly running for
just one certified fresh season starting
back in 2002
this sci-fi drama from creator joss
whedon takes place a few hundred years
in the future
and follows a renegade crew embarking on
galactic missions for profit
with nathan fillion manning the mission
as captain malcolm reynolds critics said
firefly earned its adoration with his
dry delivery plus a detailed fantasy
world and compelling story lines you can
binge this show in just over 10 hours of
binge time and then you can decide if
you think it's too dark which is why it
was ultimately cancelled by fox
next is our brand new pick and that is
going to the animated series
star wars the clone wars with the
seventh and final season wrapping up
earlier this year this show about yoda
anakin and the jedi knights fighting in
the clone wars turned in four 100
fresh seasons during its run critics
have called this series one of star wars
greatest entries praising the show for
its sophisticated storytelling
quality animation and for being a fun
kid-friendly chapter of the franchise's
sprawling mythology
it'll take you just under 51 hours to
binge this series and by that point you
gotta be one with the force right
howling away is our editor's pick this
week is the lone wolf and cub
film franchise this manga story screams
mandalorian as it's centered around an
assassin father and his three-year-old
son who travel together seeking revenge
it was first published in 1970 and was
eventually adapted into
six films released between 1972 and
1974.
over the years critics have praised the
sword work of the actors and twists and
turns of the story saying that this
franchise has a rare type of film that
succeeds as low brow visceral
entertainment or is high concept art
you can binge all six movies in just
about eight and a half hours and maybe
you'll pick up a few pointers on how to
entertain
a young child and finally our certified
fresh pick this week is going to the cbs
all-access series star trek picard this
follow-up series to star trek the next
generation features patrick stewart
reprising his role as john luke picard
in the later stages of his life
the first season features a few
appearances from other popular next-gen
characters like william riker
and data and critics say that like all
great star trek the show tackles timely
themes of grace and makes for an
exciting push further into the final
frontier
season two is coming in sometime in 2021
but until then you can binge the first
season in just under eight hours and if
you're still stuck in space you might as
well watch all seven seasons of next
generation while you're at it
engage okay friends well hopefully this
will take your next few bench sessions
to a galaxy far far away
so be sure to let us know what you are
currently streaming in the comments
section and if you don't want to miss
out on any future recommendations based
around the movies and shows that you
love
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always we can't
thank you enough for watching
binge guide and we'll see you guys next
time bye
[Music]
you